[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
jury selection begins in the trial for
the death of a mod arbory and convicted
murderer robert durst hospitalized with
copenhagen he's going to appeal
the conviction
but i don't know that he's going to
last another
six months plus could kobe bryant's
widow be subjected to a psychiatric exam
why los angeles county has vanessa
bryant be evaluated and later a kenosha
shooting victim takes legal action
saying emergency responders condone
violent white nationalist acts law and
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin nearly two years after the
shooting death of ahmad arbury the trial
against his accused killers begins with
jury selection and what's expected to be
a weeks-long trial jury selection began
monday with defense and prosecution
going head-to-head about questions for
potential jurors
all this as three georgian men face
charges of malice murder felony murder
and other related charges in the death
of 25 year old black man ahmad arbury in
february 2020 aubry was shot and killed
while jogging near his brunswick georgia
home he was unarmed at the time of his
death father and son duo gregory and
trouse mcmichael tailed aubry in a
pickup truck before traffic michael's
shot and killed him the player claimed
self-defense and used a georgia
citizen's arrest law that has since been
repealed and replaced the mcmichael's
neighbor william bryan followed along in
his truck capturing the entire incident
on his cell phone the shooting created
national outrage after that cell phone
video went viral in may of last year
after that gregory and travis mcmichael
were arrested followed by brian's arrest
two weeks later all three men have pled
not guilty to the charges on monday
prosecution and defense attorneys
address the racial uproar the shooting
created and how will affect jury
selection
in the beginning the vast majority of
media coverage characterized the
defendants
as
white racist murderers
who
saw a mod arbory in their white
neighborhood out for a sunday jog and so
they got in their truck
with guns
chased trapped and executed him in fact
those are the exact words that the state
used in the preliminary hearing in june
2020.
do you agree with the statement
this case has been important in
revealing the racism in our community
well what has that got to do with the
guilt or innocence of these defendants
about the aftermath of this case and
everything that took place
asking the jurors
do you believe this makes this person a
racist do you believe this makes this
person a racist so there's a propounding
of a number of questions where they want
the juror to say
i guess that oh yeah if somebody does
this i automatically think they're a
racist
those sorts of questions um
i think are inappropriate especially for
vaudir
number 23
white people who use the n-word are
racist
getting them to agree or disagree with
that statement
inside the courtroom focused on the
legality of racial tensions within the
trial race also weighs heavily on the
minds of georgia residents over the
weekend dozens took to the streets
rallying together for justice in the
death of a mod arbory this video taken
by law and crime network supervising
producer stephen lawrence shows the
peaceful protest calling for change for
capital gavel coverage of the trial
follow law and crime network for live
updates and for the latest trial news
day by day stay tuned to law and crime
daily
joining us today is legal analyst suen
robinson and terry austin suanne 60
jurors reported to court after a
thousand questionnaires went out to the
community is this a lot or does it make
sense for a trial like this
well you know what they say the bigger
the better and i think in this case the
idea was the bigger the jury pool the
better chances there is of finding an
unbiased unfair
i mean unbiased fair jury in this case i
think when you have a high-profile
community polarizing case where a
high-ranking official
involved in the case has been indicted
you have to really expand the pool in
order to
find people who have who exposure to the
case has not affected their ability to
look at the facts impartially and i
think that's what they're trying to do
makes a lot of sense and we'll see if
that actually works out terry we can see
what's being discussed outside the
courtroom what issues do you think will
be discussed in this jury selection
well inside the courtroom the judge is
going over the voidier questions he made
some procedural issues and he determined
those issues so for instance he said he
himself would not read the indictment
that is for the state to do he also made
sure that he gave out the right number
of strikes there's nine total he split
those up between the defendants and gave
them extra so at the end of the day each
of them will now have eight and he also
gave the state some extra strikes but he
made some substantive issues too brian
he did say that a question about the
confederate flag could come in he also
said that there would not be any
discussion about political issues like
the name of the prior da's that wasn't
relevant he said all right seems like
the judge is running a tight ship let's
see how that continues as we continue to
follow the mod arboret trial thank you
both on to bryan laundry news now this
week marks one month since the manhunt
began for the wanted fugitive many
questions are still unanswered as
officials continue to survey the florida
preserve where laundry's parents said he
went hiking in early september longie
returned home from a cross-country road
trip without fiance gabby petito he was
staying with his parents at their
northport florida home when he told them
he was going hiking in a nearby reserve
laundry left without a cell phone or
wallet gabby petito was reported missing
days earlier on september 11th her
remains were found in wyoming on
september 19th
her death was ruled a homicide by
strangulation a warrant for laundry's
arrest was issued in late september
citing unauthorized use of a debit card
and in florida a man accused of killing
his wife three children and the family
dog appears in court ahead of his
upcoming trial anthony toti was arrested
in january 2020 when the bodies of his
wife children and dog were found in the
family home after missing for weeks
toti's children ranged from age 13 to
just 4 years old he originally took
responsibility for the murders but later
blamed his wife a trial was set to begin
on september 27th but prosecutors wanted
to delay the start to sift through large
amounts of evidence the trial is now set
to begin on november 1st toti is
pleading not guilty to four counts of
first-degree murder and one count of
animal cruelty
still ahead on law and crime daily wife
of late kobe bryant to appear in court
while los angeles county says vanessa
bryant needs to undergo psychiatric
evaluation but first robert durst is
back in the hospital this time with a
coveted diagnosis what next for the real
estate air turned convicted killer
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
we are going to make sure that we find
justice in this case the three men
charged will now stand trial i told him
stop stop stop till he hit me i had
nothing to do i could i just nothing
else i could do you're a passer buyer
coming through not necessarily
that's my son that shot him i was at the
back of the truck
starting october 18th watch live galvado
gavel coverage on the law and crime
network
[Music]
welcome back days after robert durst
gets a life sentence for the murder of
his best friend he's hospitalized with
covet 19. law and crimes angina levy is
here with what this could mean for durst
conviction and a report on a grand jury
is hearing evidence against him in new
york anjanette
brian robert durst's lawyer dick degarin
says that durst will appeal his
conviction for susan berman's murder
however he doesn't know if
durst will actually live that long his
health was already failing before the
trial started
when robert durst appeared in court for
sentencing last week it looked like he
was having trouble breathing the
following day he was admitted to the
hospital for covet 19 and placed on a
ventilator according to his lawyer i
hadn't seen him in a couple of weeks
and he had looked even worse
yesterday than the last time i saw him
that was dick degarin last friday in his
first tv interview since the trial
talking about durst's health
deteriorating that day durst was taken
to the hospital his hospitalization
comes as news 12 reports the district
attorney in westchester county is
presenting evidence to a grand jury in
the disappearance of durst's first wife
kathy mccormick durst robert durst has
long denied having anything to do with
kathy's disappearance her body has never
been found but durst has been suspected
of killing kathy for years
however in telling where kathy is
perhaps you can find some small
redemption in an act of humanity susan
berman's godson sarah kaufman made a
plea to robert durst during the
sentencing i hope in your final days and
hours you will come to the same
understanding and give the mccormicks
what little they are asking for to find
kathy
to layer to rest appropriately finally
and at long last meanwhile dick degeron
says he's seen the same reports about
the grand jury but hasn't spoken with
the prosecutor in new york
frankly if there is a fair
grand jury
presentation made in westchester there
will be no indictment because there's no
evidence
now if robert durst dies before his
appeal is exhausted his conviction
in susan berman's murder would be
vacated meaning it just it's as if it
never happened at all a westchester
county da's office spokesperson would
not comment on the reports that a grand
jury is hearing evidence currently
against robert durst brian
thanks internet back to discuss the
health and future of robert durst's
legal analyst suen robinson and terry
austin terry what do you think is in the
store for dirk sick with covet post
sentencing
you know i think first and foremost we
hope that he does get the medical
treatment that he needs he is or was in
a correctional facility in los angeles
presumably he's back in the same
hospital where he was previously
hospitalized when he got sick once
before you know the hipaa laws prevent
them from telling us anything too
specific but as antoinette said de garan
already confirmed that he has been
hospitalized and that he is on a
ventilator so he's 78 years old brian we
know that he has bladder cancer and many
other ailments so hopefully he will
survive post-sentencing and hopefully
the westchester county will be able to
bring an indictment or whatever else
happens up in westchester i mean
speaking of westchester will this affect
the western grand jury will they still
push forward if durst could possibly die
i think they will still push forward
until it's apparent or certain that you
know he's no longer living i think this
isn't a case where justice delayed is
absolutely possibly about to become
justice denied if robert durst passes
away before he's able to be indicted by
the westchester grand jury or certainly
be sentenced so it's just an unfortunate
situation where robert durst is you know
being brought to justice at such a late
stage in his life as a septuagenarian
that's extremely unhealthy as opposed to
years ago when he was first
tried for these cases that the state
attorney in susan berman's case said
they were going to prove three crimes
and apparently the jury agreed that he
did so i understand the mccormick's
position listen if if susan's death was
proven it was to cover up that he killed
his wife so it's just a tough situation
where he you know he's a sceptogenarian
his health is failing and time is
running out
absolutely now anjanette what are kathy
durst family members and their lawyers
saying about the grand jury reports and
dursa's diagnosis
well brian you know i emailed kathy
mccormick's brother last week and he put
me in touch with his lawyers and they
really said they could not comment at
this time and then i emailed them again
about this covid19 diagnosis
and they did not respond to that email
obviously this is something you know the
family has been waiting for for almost
40 years now they've believed for
decades that robert durst um killed
kathy durst so they've been waiting for
a grand jury investigation and an
indictment so we can only assume that
they are watching this whole process
unfold very closely yeah we'll see how
that process unfolds and when we get an
update we'll be sure to bring it to you
coming up on law and crime daily the
surviving victim of the kenosha unrest
says law enforcement officers enabled
the deadly shootings plus los angeles
county demands a psychiatric evaluation
for kobe bryant's widow why she may have
to undergo evaluation for an upcoming
lawsuit
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily los
angeles county is calling for vanessa
bryant to undergo a psychiatric exam
before her lawsuit can go to trial this
comes nearly two years after beloved nba
legend kobe bryant tragically died in a
helicopter crash in january of 2020. the
13-year-old daughter gianna also died
along with seven other passengers after
that brian's widow vanessa filed a
lawsuit against l.a county for invasion
of privacy and negligence arguing the
county employees improperly shared
photos of human remains at the site of
the crash according to the documents the
lawsuit stems from claims of severe
emotional distress due to the release of
the photos the county maintains that
employees did nothing wrong arguing that
vanessa bryant suffered emotional
distress from the crash itself rather
than the photos that were shared of the
remains county officials argue that
plaintiffs must prove they are suffering
from ongoing depression anxiety and
severe emotional distress they say that
they must be done through a psychiatric
evaluation right now the case is
scheduled for trial in february 2022
let's bring back legal analyst suanne
robinson and co-host terry austin terry
making the victims take an exam is that
typical of these types of cases
brian it's not unusual in a civil
lawsuit to make the plaintiff prove
their damages so for instance they would
have to show that they have some bills
or invoices from having gone to a
physician or a psychiatrist but here
asking them to submit to a psychiatric
exam that is very intrusive i agree with
the plaintiffs that that would make it
extremely intrusive so
clearly the plaintiffs were distressed
by the incident any family member is
going to be distressed because their
family member has been killed in a
helicopter crash but also you can
imagine that it would be distressed
knowing that these pictures were out
there so i think as an alternative what
the judge could do is demand that the
defendants in this case have their own
psychiatrist come to testify to talk
about whether those photos would be
distressing
interesting now so does the county have
a point that they can't separate the
harm of losing a lost one to that of
these leaked photos and what does that
mean if they can't separate the two
the county doesn't have a point the
county is doing too much obviously
they're trying to cover liability of one
of their own employees that admittedly
leaked the photos so to me this is
something that should be stipulated to
i think we're all just generally
civilians know that if you're in a
situation where your loved one has
passed away seeing their images on tv
before you even have the opportunity to
identify them and deal with the grief
speak to your other family members is
going to be distressing much less for
someone who lives their life in the
public eye and is publicly losing two
members of their family at the same time
so i just think l.a county is doing too
much they can stipulate to it i get it
defend defense attorneys are gonna
defend but this is too much absolutely i
would tend to agree with you there and
in other top legal news a west coast
judge rules in favor of two prominent
journalists in the federal trial of
elizabeth holmes
on thursday a judge cited in favor of
john kerry weeks after defense added him
to the witness list back in 2015
careyroom broke the theron's fraud story
that would be the catalyst for holmes's
charges after that holmes's defense team
added caryroo to the witness list
something the journalist's attorneys
called a ruse so that he could not cover
the trial as a witness kerry roo could
have faced an exclusion order meaning a
witness cannot be in the courtroom for
other witness testimony or a gag order
meaning a witness cannot discuss their
testimony on thursday magistrate judge
nathaniel cousins ruled that kerryroo
should be considered an expert witness
rather than a fact witness that means
cairo can be present in the courtroom
and report on the trial for his podcast
the same judge also denied a defense
motion that would have required reporter
roger parloff to hand over his reporter
notes and audio clips holmes the former
ceo of now defunct company theranos
faces 12 counts of fraud for her time
with the company holmes claimed theranos
would revolutionize blood testing but
later tests found many problems with
ethereum's devices
when we come back a surviving victim of
the kenosha shootings sues the city
how gay makrowski blames kenosha
wisconsin for allowing vigilantes to
patrol the streets the night that he
lost most of his biceps
[Music]
welcome back just weeks before the trial
of accused kenosha shooter kyle
rittenhouse is set to begin a shooting
victim files a lawsuit against wisconsin
authorities claiming they enabled deadly
violence at the riots
in august 2020 gage groskowitz was shot
and severely injured during the kenosha
unrest shootings he lost 90 percent of
his bicep after being shot now
girlsquist has filed a lawsuit against
the city county and several law
enforcement officers claiming that they
supported the efforts of white
nationalists that showed up at the
protests the rally began after the
shooting of jacob blake an unarmed black
man who was shot by police
authorities say 18-year-old kyle
rittenhouse showed up at the rallies
wielding a rifle he shot and killed
anthony hubber and joseph rosenbaum in
the shootings groskowitz was shot and
severely injured but survived his
lawsuit claims that authorities new
armed vigilantes plan to patrol the
protests and welcome their participation
the lawsuit says quote it was not a
mistake that kyle renthouse shot and
killed two people and maimed a third it
goes on to say that it was quote a
natural consequence of the actions of
the police department the trial for kyle
rain house is set to begin with jury
selection on november 1st
so man what facts would need to come out
for this civil case for the plaintiff to
win his claim and do you think it's even
possible
aside from the fact that i strongly
think kyle rittenhouse should have been
at home doing his homework with respect
to the case i think that they're gonna
have to show that the police had a duty
obviously and that the duty was breached
in terms of parts of the case that
allege racial discrimination saying that
the police allowed white
nationalists to
do what they wanted to but were being
tougher on
non-white nationalist
protesters i don't think he has standing
there but i think to demonstrate that
somehow the police were working in
conjunction or almost supporting kyle
rittenhouse specifically perhaps
allowing him to walk around with the gun
i mean forgiveness six the gun is bigger
than his body they didn't need to see
his id to see that it's an underage kid
walking around with a huge firearm so if
he walked by some police officers and
got a pat on the back then they would be
in the game to show that the police kind
of sanctioned or allowed the conduct but
shy of that it's going to be very tough
to show that there was a breach of the
police's duty or the city's duty to
protect citizens absolutely now terry
how much of the verdict in reyna house's
case is going to affect this civil
lawsuit what do you think
well theoretically it really should have
no effect but realistically brian it
really will have a great deal of effect
on the civil case if he's found not
guilty there's an implication that the
city's not responsible so i think it
would really help as far as the civil
lawsuit's concerned absolutely and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you